what i want to do in this video is kind
of introduce you to the idea of one how
carbon 14
comes about and how it gets into all
living things and then in either later
this video or in future videos we'll
talk about how it's actually used to
date things how we use it to actually
figure out that that bone is 12 000
years old that that person died 18 000
years ago whatever it might be so let me
draw
the earth so let me just draw the
surface of the earth like that it's just
a little section of the surface of the
earth and then we have the atmosphere of
the earth
i'll draw that in yellow so then you
have the earth's atmosphere
right over here we write that down
atmosphere
atmosphere and 78 the most abundant the
most abundant element in our atmosphere
is nitrogen it is 78
nitrogen and i'll write nitrogen it's
its symbol is just n and it has seven
protons and it also has seven neutrons
so it has an atomic mass of roughly 14
then this is the most typical isotope of
nitrogen and we talk about the word
isotope in the chemistry playlist an
isotope that the protons define what
element it is but this number up here
can change depending on the number of
neutrons you have so the different
versions of a given element those are
each called isotopes i just view them in
my head as versions of an element so
anyway we have our atmosphere and then
coming from our sun we have what's
commonly called cosmic rays but they're
actually not rays they're cosmic
particles they're mainly you could view
them as just single protons which is the
same thing as a hydrogen nucleus they
can also be alpha particles which is the
same thing as a helium nucleus and
there's even a few electrons and they're
going to come in and they're going to
bump into things in our atmosphere and
they're actually going to form neutrons
so they're actually going to form
neutrons and we'll show a neutron with a
lower case n and a one for its mass
number
and and we don't write anything because
it has no protons down here like we had
for nitrogen we had seven protons so
it's not really an element it is a
subatomic
particle but you have these neutrons
formed and every now and then and i'm
not you know let's just be clear this
isn't like a typical reaction but every
now and then
one of those neutrons will bump into one
of the nitrogen 14s in just the right
way
into one of the nitrogen 14s in just the
right way
so that it it bumps off one of the
protons in the nitrogen
so it bumps off one of the protons in
the nitrogen
and essentially replaces that proton
with itself so let me make it clear so
it bumps off one of the protons so
instead of seven protons we now have six
protons but it's this number 14 doesn't
go down to 13 because it replaces it
with itself so this still stays at 14.
and now since it only has since it now
only has six protons this is no longer
nitrogen by definition this is now
carbon and that proton that was bumped
off just kind of gets emitted
so then let me just do another color so
plus and a proton that's just flying
around you could call that hydrogen
hydrogen one and it can gain an electron
some ways if it doesn't get an electron
it's just a it's just a hydrogen ion a
positive ion either way or a hydrogen
nucleus
but this process and once again it's not
a typical process but it happens every
now and then this is how carbon 14 forms
so this right here is carbon 14. you can
essentially view it as a nitrogen 14
where one of the protons is replaced
with a neutron and what's interesting
about this is this is constantly being
formed in our atmospheres not in huge
quantities but in reasonable causes let
me write this down constantly being
formed
constant
constant formation
and what happens is and let's let me be
very clear let's look at the periodic
table over here
typical carbon so carbon by definition
if you have six protons
carbon by definition it has six protons
but the typical isotope the most common
isotope of carbon is carbon 12.
so carbon 12
carbon 12 is the most common
is the most common so most of the carbon
in your body is carbon 12. but what's
interesting is is that a small fraction
of carbon 14 forms and then this carbon
14 can then also combine with oxygen to
form carbon dioxide
and then that carbon dioxide gets
absorbed into the rest of the atmosphere
into our oceans it can be
fixed by plants when people talk about
carbon fixation they're really talking
about using mainly light energy from the
sun to take gaseous carbon and turn into
actual kind of organic tissue
and so this carbon 14
this carbon 14 makes its way
makes its way it's constantly being
formed it makes its way into oceans
oceans it's already in the air but it
completely mixes through the whole
atmosphere oceans and the air and then
it makes its way into plants
and then it makes away and plants are
really just they're really just made out
of that fixed carbon that carbon that
was taken in gaseous form and put into
put into uh i guess you could say into
kind of a solid form put it into in the
living form that's what wood pretty much
is it puts it it gets put into plants
and then it gets put into the things
that that eat the plants so that could
be
that could be us now why is this why is
this even interesting i've just
explained a mechanism where some of our
body even though carbon 12 is the most
common isotope some of our body while
we're living
gets made up of this carbon-14 thing
well the interesting thing is the only
time you can take in this carbon-14 is
while you're alive while you're eating
new things because as soon as you die
and you get buried under the ground
there's no way for the carbon 14 to
become part of your tissue anymore
because it's not being you're not eating
anything with new carbon 14.
and what's interesting here is once you
die
you're not going to get any new carbon
14 and that carbon 14 that you did have
at your death
is going to
so the carbon 14 that you did have
is going to decay is going to decay
via beta decay and we learned about this
back into
back into nitrogen 14. so the kind of
this process reverses
so it'll decay back into nitrogen 14 and
beta decay you emit an electron and an
electron anti-neutrino and we'll go into
the details of that but essentially what
you have happening here is you have one
of the neutrons is turning into a proton
and emitting and emitting this stuff in
the process now why is this interesting
so i just said while you're living you
have kind of straight up carbon 14 as
soon as
and carbon 14 is constantly doing this
decay thing but what's interesting is as
soon as you die and and you're not
ingesting any more plants or any or
breathing from the atmosphere if you are
a plant or fixing from the atmosphere
and this even applies to plants once the
plant dies it's no longer taking in
carbon dioxide from the atmosphere
and turning it into new tissue
the carbon 14 in that tissue gets frozen
and this carbon 14 does this decay over
at a specific rate
at a specific rate and then you can use
that rate to actually determine how long
ago that thing must have died so the
rate the rate at which this happens
so the rate
of carbon 14 decay is essentially half
disappears half gone
half gone
in
roughly five thousand seven hundred and
thirty
five thousand and seven hundred and
thirty years and this is actually called
a half-life
and we talk about it in other videos
this is called a half-life and i wanna
be clear here you don't know which half
of it's gone it's a probabilistic thing
you can't just say oh all of the carbon
14s on the left are going to decay and
all the carbon 14s on the right aren't
going to decay that 5730 years what it's
essentially saying is any given carbon
14 atom has a 50 chance of decaying into
nitrogen 14 in 5 730 years so over the
course of 5 730 years roughly half of
them will have decayed now why is that
why is that interesting
well if you know that all living things
have a certain proportion of carbon 14
in their
in their in their tissue it as kind of
part of what makes them up and then if
you were to find some bone
let's just say find some bone
right here
that you know you dig it up on some type
of archaeology dig and you say hey that
bone has
one half the carbon 14
one half the carbon 14 of of all the
living things that you see right now so
you could it would be a pretty
reasonable
estimate to say well that thing must be
5730 years old even better maybe you you
dig a little deeper and you find another
bone
maybe you find another bone maybe a
couple of feet even deeper
and you say wow you know this thing
right over here has one-fourth the
carbon-14 this has one-fourth the
carbon-14 that i would expect to find in
something living so how old is this well
if only has one fourth the carbon-14 it
must have gone through two half-lives
after one half-life it would have had
it would have one half the carbon and
then after another half-life half of
that also turns into a nitrogen 14.
and so this would involve two half-lives
two half-lives which is the same thing
as two times five thousand and seven
hundred thirty years
or you would say that this thing is this
thing is what this thing is ten thousand
you would say this thing is eleven
thousand four hundred
and sixty
years old give or take